we have new information about Dwayne
Johnson's furious rant against his fast
eight co-stars and Therese want you to
know while the rock is not talking about
him so who is the target of Dwayne's now
infamous tirade more and more signs are
pointing to Vin Diesel here's what we
know they've battled it out on the big
screen and now it appears Vin Diesel and
the rock are locked in a fast a few
behind the scenes this mega big mistake
the rock went on an Instagram ramp
earlier this week ripping into male
co-stars for being unprofessional and
candy blanks
turns out the post was apparently
directed at co star and producer Vin
Diesel due to have reportedly clashed
during production and held a secret
meeting to talk it out trying to make a
movie then we'll be proud of VIN
Facebook from set just after the rocks
post a source close to VIN tells us he
wrapped shooting in Atlanta earlier this
morning and is now back in LA here's
another twist franchise co-star Tyrese
Gibson had a message for fans The Rock's
rant it's not about me happy he posted
and later deleted this Instagram video
of the rock serenading his daughter
riding a man wouldn't be singing from
his heart and soul to another man's
little angel if he had a problem with
her dad he went on does any of us know
why bro decided to jump out there with
his post no would one assume that if
he's going to jump out there and
generalize and say male co-stars he
would be more clear and call out names
of course he should have no egos no
politics no drama that was just getting
in there having a good time
Tyrese was loving life when we talked to
him about Fast Five and his comments are
more interesting than ever in light of
us supposed Ben rock feud somebody knew
like the rock coming on board it's like
we welcome the energy because a lot of
us can get into this feeling of
teittleman - I was here first